ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูหญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์
วันจันทร์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4
ค่ะวันที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายนปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีพ.ศ 2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 ใส่ค่ะใหญ่
ผู้หญิงคะแล้วตอนนี้ช่วงเวลากี่โมงตอนนี้
เวลา
15:00 น
22 นาทีค่ะบ่าย3โมง 22 นาทีนะคะค่ะก็ผู้
หญิงนักเรียนของเรามาหรือยังนักเรียนมา
หรือยังมาแล้วยกมือโห้นักเรียนยกมือแล้ว
ยกมือแล้วมีกี่คนคะครูหญิงวันนี้เรามีนัก
เรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11
โขน S คนเยอะ
ก็
มี 11 คนแล้วดังคะ
ผู้หญิงนะคะเป็นคนที่ 11 นักเรียนคะมี
กระดาษไหมคะกระดาษเพราะมีนะคะมีปากกาไหม
คะปากกาเรียนพยักหน้าค่ะปากกานักเรียนมี
กระดาษมีปากกานะคะนักเรียนเขียนชื่อนะคะ
ชื่อครูชื่อเอ๋เอ๋นะคะหนูชื่ออะไรนะคะครู
ชื่อหญิงค่ะครูชื่อหญิงคู่หญิงกับครูเอ๋
เอ๋นะคะทางนั้นเขียนชื่อหาบอกครูนะบอกครู
หญิงตัว a จะได้รู้จักนักเรียนวันนะค่ะ
ชื่ออะไรนะคะนักเรียนเขียนนะคะคะแล้วก็ยก
กระดาษให้ครูดูค่ะเขียนก่อนนะผู้หญิงเห็น
ไหมนักเรียนเขียนว่าอะไรนักเรียนยกกระดาษ
แล้วค่ะค่ะเห็นแล้วผู้หญิงเขียนให้เพื่อน
ๆดูได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะนักเรียนเขียนว่า
oeng
[เพลง]
พูดอะไรพูดอะไรอ่ะ
ต้อง
เก่ง
ค่ะนักๆนามสกุลไหมคะนามสกุล
น้ำน้ำนามสกุล
ge-e  k  k  s  u  n
ไม่เห็นไม่เห็นเห็น
ถ้าหากอ่านว่าในจิอิคุณ
นักเรียนมาบอก
ไม่แน่ใจเนาะออกเสียงว่าอะไรก็ขอโทษนะคะ
อ่า
โอเคนะนักเรียนอ่อนแม่จะชื่อคุยคิดพูด
อะไรคิดชื่อให้นักเรียนไหมกาดอันนี้อ๋อ
เดี๋ยวนะโอเค ang อ้ะนักเรียนเป็นผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชาย
นักเรียน
ผู้หญิงค่ะนักเรียนบอกว่าค่ะนักเรียนเป็น
ผู้หญิงเรียนเป็นอ๋อ
คุณงั้นให้ชื่อคุณโอ๋คุณโอโอ้มีตัว O  O
ใช่ไหมคะดีจ้า
คุณโอ
ออกโอเอง
โอ่งอุ้ยคุณโอก่อนแล้วกันคุณโอนะคะคุณโอ
ไม่มีคนที่ 11 ของเราชื่อคุณโอโอ้โอ
เย้
สวยใส่ค่ะเป็นผู้หญิงนอนตอนนี้เราก็มีนัก
เรียนผู้หญิง 4 คนค่ะนักเรียนผู้ชาย
7 คนนะคะก็ 11 คนแล้วเย้
12 ไหม 12 อยู่ที่ไหนคอมเม้นนะคะ 12
52 มา
เราอยากได้นักเรียนมากๆใช่ไหมใครค่ะจะได้
รู้ดีนะเรียนค่ะงั้นเราเรารอนะเรารอรอรอ
นักเรียนคนที่ติดต่อ 2 นะคะเราก็อ้ะต้อน
รับณดินดีต้อนรับนักเรียนคนที่ 11 นะคะ
ที่โกคุณโอ๋สวัสดีค่ะ
ยินดีต้อนรับค่ะค่ะนะคะคนที่ 11 ของเรา
ว่าในผู้หญิงเรามีนักเรียนคนที่ 11 แล้ว
พี่เอ๋มีคำถามไหมคะวันนี้ตัวเองมีคำถาม
เลยครับอีกนะจ๊ะโอเคเพลงเกมผู้หญิงมือนะ
ก็บีบอันนี้จะมาปิดจมูกค่ะอ่าโอเคไม่จาม
แล้ว
จ้าม
3 นะคะแต่
ไอหาค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋มีคำถามว่าผู้หญิงผู้หญิงพูดปาก
ใช่ไหมคะเขาเนี่ยปากปากแล้วก็พูดพูดพูด
ทุกวันทุกวันแล้วก็นั่งใช่ไหมมีเก้าอี้
แล้วก็นั่ง
ข้างหน้าอันนี้หน้าหน้านะคะแล้วก็ข้าง
หน้าคือคอมพิวเตอร์
ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันเบื่อ
ช่วยตอกไหม
เบื่อเบื่อค่ะครูเอ๋
เบื่อใช่ไหม
อีกวันเบื่อทุกวันดูคอมพิวเตอร์ดูครูเอ๋
ดูหรือเตอร์
กูยังบอกดูคอมพิวเตอร์ดูครูเอ๋เบื่อ
ยังไม่เสร็จยังไม่เล่นเสือดุ
ดูครูฟ้าด้วยอ่ะจะได้เบื่อ 2 คน
ผู้หญิงเบื่อกูฟ้าเบื่อเห
รออยากเปลี่ยนดูคอมพิวเตอร์และก็ดูครูเอ๋
ที่ไม่ใช่ในคอนโดมิเนียมเพราะว่า
คอนโดมิเนียม Condominium เบื่อ
คอมพิวเตอร์นะคะครูเอกก็เบื่อ
นักเรียนเบื่อเราไหมฮะนักเรียนซ่านายหน้า
ค่าเปลี่ยนสายนะนักเรียนไม่เบื่อใช่ไหม
ไม่ให้เบื่อนักเรียนบอกดูครูหญิงดูครูเอ๋
ทุกวันโอเค
ไหมเบื่อขอ
ใครไม่เบื่อคอมเมนท์นะคะคุณ
ครับถ้าเบื่อโทรไม่ต้อง comment นะคะ
สารชัยค่ะ
ไม่เบื่อคอมเมนท์เบื่อไม่คอมเมนต์โอเคนะ
โอเคดิว
เออเบื่อเนาะงั้นอยากไปเที่ยวไหมคุย
อยากไปอยากไปเที่ยวอยากไปเที่ยวครูเอกก็
อยากไปเที่ยว
ยายไปข้างนอก
มั้ยไม่ใช่อพาร์ทเม้นท์ไม่ใช่
คอนโดมิเนียมอยากไปเที่ยวไปดูไปถ่ายรูป
พรุ่งนี้โทรศัพท์
ถ่ายรูปไป
ผู้หญิงยิ้มๆ
ถ่ายรูป
ผู้หญิงขั้ว S ขายไหมคัด
ผู้หญิง Action เร็วจะเอาๆเอาใหม่กูอ่ะ
แบบนี้อ่ะอ่ะ
แชะแชะแชะแชะแชะแชะๆผู้หญิงผอมบ่อ้าย
ครูให้ฉันเรียนแพะ
มันก็ถ่ายรูปไงถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปตัวเอกกำลัง
ปลดใช่มั้ยกดกดดังหาข่าวโอเคเผื่อเราก็
อยากไปเที่ยวแต่ก่อนจะไปเที่ยวเราก็ต้อง
คิดเองไปเที่ยวที่ไหนอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีไหมคะมีให้ดูไหมไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ต้องคิดก่อนนะไอ้ไปผู้หญิง
อยากไปอเมริกาไว้อ่ะถ้าไม่อยากไปเดี๋ยว
นักเรียนอเมริกาเยอะเลยนะ
เอ้าตอนนี้มากๆนะเยอะๆนะ
ไม่อยากไปไงตอนนี้คิดประเทศไทยอ๋อประเทศ
ไทยอ๋อไม่อยากไปเอาเมริกาอยากไปเที่ยวที่
ประเทศไทยอ่ะคู๋มีรูปให้ผู้หญิงดู
โหม่งทำสิ่งใหญ่ๆโอ๋นักเรียนดูด้วยนะได้
ค่ะแล้วก็ก็นักเรียนอยากไปไหมถ้านักเรียน
ยางไปพยนาคค่ะไม่อยากไปทำยังไงคะตายหน้า
ค่ะไม่อยากไปอยากไปไม่อยากไปนะคะโอเค
เดี๋ยวคู๋ให้ดูได้ค่ะ A  Share  Screen
นะคะได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
การตั้งแต่นาอ้าวพก
มาไหมหน้ามั้ยอ้ะผู้หญิงแล้วค่ะเด่นค่ะ
คุณขยับไปทางรูปเล็กนิหนึ่งได้ไหมคะ
ได้ค่ะดีมากเลยค่ะครูเอ๋ตรงนั้นแหละบาย
ค่ะดีค่ะดีเลยค่ะเพราะว่าครูเอ๋ไม่ได้
เป็นคนเล็กคอร์ดคู๋ไม่เห็นมีไว้ตรงนี้ดี
มากนักเรียนเห็นรูปเห็นครูหอโอเคนะงูรีบ
นี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋น้ำตกค่ะโอ๊ะน้ำตกชื่อ
อะไรน้ำตกชื่อเครอซู
อยู่ที่ไหนอ่ะประเทศไทยหรอประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทย
โอ๊ยโอ๊ย
ดูถูกประเทศไทยอ่ะได้ค่ะวันนี้ยังไม่บอก
ตรงไหนอยู่ประเทศไทยแต่ให้ดู
เข้าสู่ใหญ่ไหมคะผู้หญิงใช่อีคาครูเอ๋อิฐ
เล็กแล้วก็ใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะ
สูงโอเคและสูง
สูงนะคะครูเอ๋สูงค่ะใหญ่เราก็สูง
แล้วก็คุยไม่มีอะไรคะ
นะคะอันนี้อะไรน่ะ
ต้นไม้
ต้นไม้นะคะมีต้นไม้มากๆใช่ไหมค่ะต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้มากๆนะน้ำตกทีลอซู
เนี่ยอยู่ที่ภูภูเขาเนาะกะสายน้ำตกอยู่
ที่ภูเขาเสือภูเขาครูผู้หญิงเห็นน้ำตก
ทีลอซู
yok ไปไหมคะ
ไม่อยากไปค่ะทำไมสวย
สูงอะไรผู้หญิงไม่อยากไปน้ำตกทีลอซูสวย
มากยิ่งมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้
ต้นไม้เยอะๆไม่อยากไปนี่
ครูหญิงครูกลัว
ต้นมาให้เหรอคะ
กลัวนทร์ภูเขาค่ะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงกลัว
กูเขา
ขอครูหญิงไม่อยากไปน้องล้มทีรอซูราคานัก
เรียน
โป้นักเรียนหนูอยากไปน้ำตกที่รอโซไหมคะ
นะเรียนพยักหน้าอยากไป
พยักหน้า
12 คนหรอคะ 11 ค่ะ 11 คนอีกหนึ่งคนใคร
เราเรามี 11 คนค่ะครูเอ๋ตอนนี้
คนที่ 12 เรารอ 12 ค่ะครูเอ๋
ขอโทษค่ะ
โอเค 11 คนพยักหน้าอ๋ออยากไปทีลอโซนะคะ
ค่ะ R
ประเทศไทยค่ะค่ะทรายนะคะมาประเทศไทยน้ำตก
ทีลอซูสวยนะคะอ่าเดือน
เดือนอะไรครับสวย
เดือนที่ 11 มา
ถึงเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
[เพลง]
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนถึงเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
สวยสีนักเรียนต้องมาเดือนนี้มาๆนะคะ
ต่อไปผู้หญิงบอกไม่เอาน้ำตกทีลอซูซูไม้
ใหญ่ต้นไม้มาก
กลัวหนาไม่อยากไปไม่อยากไปโอเคผู้หญิงไป
ดูน้ำตกที่สอง
หูกุ้ง
ยังไงโง่
สวยค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋น้ำตกชื่ออะไรคะน้ำตกชื่อ
น้ำตก
เจ็ดสาวน้อยอ่า
ก็เป็นมันมีผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงส่งศพ 7 ครบค่า
สามสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดร้อยห้า
ขอน้ำตกผู้หญิง 7 คน
อ่ะผู้หญิง
อายุนิดหน่อย
ยายสาวๆอายุ 16 ปีเนาะอ่าค่ะถึง 19 ปี
เนาะหน้าใช่ๆประมาณนี้อ่ะอายุ 16 ถึง 19
ปีเราเรียกว่าสาวน้อยมีท่อน้ำตกเจ็ดสาว
น้อย
ได้น้ำตกชื่อเจ็ดสาวน้อย
3 ก็ผู้หญิงอายุในน้อยภาษาไทยเมื่อแต่
เมื่อก่อนเนาะสาวน้อยราคา
น้ำตกชื่อเจ็ดสาวน้อย
สวยไหมคะผู้หญิงสวยค่ะครูเอ๋ใหญ่ไหมคะพี่
ไอใหญ่ล่ะคะสูงไหมคะไม่สวยสูงเตี้ยเตี้ย
เตี้ยเตี้ยราคา
ผู้หญิงคะครูหญิงอยากไปน้ำตกเจ็ดสาวน้อย
ไหม
ฉาดไปค่ะครูเองอยากไปอยากไปเดี๋ยวที่เรา
สู่ไม่อยากไป
เจ็ดสาวน้อยอยากไปทำไมคะ
เจ็ดสาวน้อยเบี้ยค่ะอ๋อ
เปี้ยๆต้นไม้นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยอ่ะฮะโอเค
นักเรียนค่ะนักเรียนอยากไปอยากไปเที่ยวนะ
ระวังอยากไปเที่ยวน้ำตกเจ็ดสาวน้อยไหมคะ
โอ้นักเรียนพยักหน้าอย่าไปขอนักเรียนยาว
ไปทหาร
โอเคครูเอ๋ก็ยากหรืออยากไปรู้เหลีงรอซู
ครูเอ๋อยากไปไหมคะครูเอ๋
เมื่อก่อนไป 2 ครั้งแล้ว
ก็อาจจะไม่อยากไปก็ไม่อยากไปแล้วค**อยาก
ไปเจ็ดสาวน้อยนรกอย่างไรน้ำตกเจ็ดสาวน้อย
ค่ะมีอีกไหมคะรู๋น้ำตกไปละคู่ขอจบไม่มี
แล้วไม่รู้
กูขาวหูเขา
ภูเขา
[เพลง]
เหล็กขยับขยับขยับขยับขยับรูปอ่ะขยายด้วย
นะคะได้ค่ะโอเค
ภูเขาค่ะผู้หญิงผู้เขารูปนี้ชื่ออะไรคะ
ชื่อครูกระดึง
องค์
นะคะ
ถ่ายรูปมาสวยครูผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอยากไป
เที่ยวถูกกระดึงไหมคะ
ช้าไปค่ะครูเอ๋
อยากไปผู้หญิงคุณครูกันแดง
สูงมากๆต้องเดินเดินๆ
เดินขึ้นนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอย่าไปเหนื่อยนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอยากเดินอยากไปขอกู้หญิงอยากเดิน
ขึ้นหู่กระดึงใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงอยากนั่งตรง
นี้ screw เอ๋ขอได้ไหมคะ
คนเดียวได้ค่ะ 5 คนไม่ดีอะพี่คนเดียวโอเค
นะ
นักเรียนราคะนักเรียนยาไปเดินขึ้นเดินนะ
เดินขึ้นภูกระดึงไหมคะโห
เด็กนักเรียนอยากไปนักเรียนอยากไปทุกที่
เลย
เดี๋ยวเจ็ดสาวน้อยนักเองก็อยากไปอยากไป
นักเรียนก็อยากไปนักเรียนอยากเดินเดิน
ขึ้นภูเขา
ดีมากนักเรียนขอโทษนะคะ
ขา
ขาแข็งแรง
โอเค
ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากไปภูกระดึงไหมคะ
ปีนี้ใช่ไหม
ไม่อยากไปอ้าว
ทำไมผู้เหวเดินขึ้นภูเขา
เหนื่อยไม่เอาเอาเอาเอาชายใจค่ะานอาหา
ต้องขา
ดีๆนะคะเดินขึ้นภูเขาโอเคใช่ค่ะบ้างต้อง
คู๋อายุเหนะคะอายุ
54 ปีปี 5 ปี
54 ปีเดินขึ้นภูกระดึงไม่ได้เอาผู้หญิง
โอเคครูคุย
ครูเรียมโอเค
สาย Arty
โอเค
เดินเดินขึ้นภูเขาค่ะมีอีกค่ะคู่หญิงมี
รูปอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงออกมายค่ะผู้
หญิงคิด
ผู้หญิงเคลียร์ตัวเองด้วยนะอ่า
ถ้าคุณเคลียร์แล้วนี่นะ
[เพลง]
เขา
โอ้โหผู้หญิงค**อยากไปเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋คะรูป
นี้ภูเขาหรอคะผู้เขาค่ะ
ภูเขา
ภูเขาในรูปนี้ชื่ออะไรคะชื่อโทรชี้ฟ้าหมู
อวย Moo  uay ชอบภูชี้ฟ้า
Where อยากไปโอ้โห
ครูหญิงยังไม่ได้ถามครูเอ๋บอกแล้วอย่าไป
แต่กูเอ๋ไม่อยากเดิน
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เห้อ
กูเอ๋อยากไปภูชี้ฟ้าแต่กูเองไม่อยากเดิน
หอภูชี้ฟ้าเหมือนภูกระดึงเดินขึ้นภูเขา
ใช่และดีกว่าภูกระดึงเดินเดินเดิน
เหนื่อยมากกว่าต่ออ๋อ
สีฟ้าก็เดินเหนื่อยนิดหน่อยค่ะแต่ว่าคุย
ชอบมีป่า
อยู่ที่นี่น้อไงบ้างอยู่ที่นี่อะอ๋ออ๋อ
ครูเอ๋อยากยืนตรงนี้ดูอะไรดูดูดูอันนี้
ค่ะคู่หญิงด้วยนะคะ
ทำไมปากกากูเอก
ดูอันนี้ค่ะดูแม่
หมูสีเขาขาวๆตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะแม่ดูใช่มั้ย
ดู
ดูพระอาทิตย์หัน
ถ่ายรูปห*อีกราคาแล้วก็
ไม่ได้ยินซูมจัด
แล้วก็ส่งเสียงดังๆอ๋อแบบ
ไป
Echo เหรอคะครูเอ๋สวัสดี
[เพลง]
การกบตะโกน
ตะโกนดังๆนะคะโอ๋เอ๋อยากยืนตรงๆตรงนี้นะ
เขาเรียกว่าน่าพักมาก
หน้าผานะคะยืนบนหน้าผาอันเนี้ยข้างบน
และข้างบนแล้วตรงเนี้ยหน้าผา
อากาศยานยืนที่อยู่ข้างบนหน้าผาแล้วก็ดู
เมฆนะแม่ดูดู
[เพลง]
พระอาทิตย์แล้วก็ตะโกนซอยวัดดี
สวัสดี
ผู้หญิงนะคะอยากไปภูชี้ฟ้าไหม
มากไปค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงอยากไปใช่ไหมสวยมาก
สวยมากสวยมากอยากไปอย่าพิมพ์นักเรียนอยาก
ไปไหมคะโหนะเรียนพยักหน้าอยากไปค่ะครูเอ๋
นักเรียนพยักหน้าทุกที่สิ่ง
ที่เราซูพยักหน้าอยากไปเจ็ดสาวน้อยน้ำตก
ทีลอซูน้ำตกเจ็ดสาวน้อยอยากไปภูกระดึง
อยากไปภูชี้ฟ้าอยากไปโอเคน้ำตกภูเขาเสร็จ
แล้วครูเอมีรูปีกค่ะผู้หญิงมีรูปอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋
ทะเล
หนูครูเอเอารูปมาขยับรูปขยับรูปเที่ยวนะ
ได้ไหม
ทะเล
ค่า
รูปนี้ที่ไหนคะครูหญิงรู้
ถ้าใครไม่รู้ค่ะครูเอ๋รูปนี้ชื่อทะเลชื่อ
อะไรคะ
พัทยาอ่ะบ้านครูฟ้านะ
พัทยา
[เพลง]
วุง
พัทยา
พัทยาผู้
Crazy สีฟ้า
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิง
พัทยาคุยหนิงขลุ่ยหญิงคุยขยับอีกหน่อยนะ
r-cooh หญิงอยากไปพัทยาไหมคะไม่อยาก
ปล่อย
เสียงไม่อยากไปไม่อยากไปเอ้าครูฟ้าร้อง
ไห้แล้วดูทีวีไม่อยากไปค่ะครูเอ๋ทำไม
คาเลไม่สวย
อันนี้ขอโทษ
พัทยา
ไม่อยากไปค่ะพัทยามีคนคนคนคนคนคนมากๆนี้
ฉันให้
ผู้หญิงไม่อยากไปพัทยานะคะเก๋
[เพลง]
ถ้า
ไม่อยากไปพัทยาค่ะไม่อยากไปเรียนหรอคะ
คนเยอะไม่อยากไปนักเรียนล่ะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนรู้สายหัวนักเรียนทราย
หัวค่ะครูเอ๋
ใส่หัวทุกคนเลยหรอคะป้าขอ
ทำไมอ่ะ
คิดว่านักเรียนดูอินเตอร์เน็ตตอนไม่อยาก
ไปพัทยาแต่โอเคนะโอเคอ่านี่โอเค
อาหารอร่อย
นะคะมีคนไทยไงพัทยาบ่อยๆก็เลยไม่อยากไปละ
ค่ะเทพพัทยาพัทยากรุงเทพกรุงเทพพัทยา
พัทยากรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯต่อไปกลับไปกลับไป
กลับก็ได้ไม่อยากไปแล้วพี่
โอเคงั้นมีให้ดูค่ะอีกทีนี้ทะเลอื่นอีก
ไหมคะมีค่ะคู่หญิงน้อ
เอกใครอยาก
เกาะสมุยหมู
หน้าเป็นอันนี้นะคะอันเนี้ยเกาะรับและ
ทะเลนี้
เป็นเกาะหน้าเป็นมีต้นมะพร้าว
ต้นมะพร้าวต้นมะพร้าวน่ะต้นเอาพระออกอีก
ไม่เห็นใช่ไหมนายชายไม่เห็นเอาชายค่ะ
เนี่ยต้นมะพร้าว
เกาะเห็นไหมว่าสอบเห็นค่ะเห็นเกาะ
พฤหัสปราสาทเกาะสมุย
นี่อยาก
จะไปเกาะสมุยไหมคะครูหญิง
อยากไปค่ะครูหญิงยาไปเกาะสมุย
นักเรียนอยากไปเกาะสมุยไหมคะ
นักเรียนบางคนอยากไปบางคนไม่อยากไปอ๋ออ๋อ
นักเรียนบางคนไม่ชอบใช่ไหมไม่อยากไปเขา
อาจจะคิดไปทะเลทรายเกาะสมุยคนคนคนมากๆนี้
แตกสวยสวยครูเอ๋อยากไปเกาะสมุยไหมคะรู้เห
ยาอยากไปเกาะสมุย
อยากไปแล้วก็เกาะสมุยนะผู้หญิงอะไรมี
วิลล่าสวยคะ
อันนี้เป็นวิลล่าไปนอนชิเกาะสมุยเหรอคะมี
วิลล่า 1 วิลล่าสุดสวย
วุ้นชื่ออะไรวิลล่าชื่ออะไร
800 สมุยกู้เงินในไปที่นี่ใช่ไหม 180
สมุยเห็นไหมคะครูเอ๋ลืมขยับเห็นค่ะเห็น
ค่ะมีเตียงนอนเนาะมีสระว่ายน้ำถ้าโอเคเขต
ให้ไหมคะนี่มีมีเตียงนอนมีสระว่ายน้ำแล้ว
ก็มีทะเล
มีอะไรคะตรงนี้ก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆอยู่
ที่ไหนอยู่บนฟ้าท้องฟ้าท้องฟ้าใช่ไหมว่าย
น้ำนอนอยู่
มาดูท้องฟ้าผู้หญิงอยากไปค่ะครูเอ๋อยากไป
นอน
อย่างนี้นี่ข้างๆในฝาเตียงที่ว่างเนี่ย
ค่ะมีจะอยู่ที่มีผู้หญิงอยู่แล้วผู้หญิง
นอนที่นี่ค่ะและจะดู
ท้องฟ้า
ผู้หญิงจะนอนตอนนี้ที่
เกาะสมุยราคา
คู่เอกก็อยากไปเกาะสมุยอยากไปนอนที่นี่
ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋คะนักเรียนเนี่ยดูรูปแล้วก็คิดออก
ตอนนี้อยากไปแล้วอยากไปแล้วใช่มั้ย
แต่ว่ามันหมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วครูเอกก็
อยากไปเที่ยวแล้วคุณอยู่อยากไปแล้วนัก
เรียนก็อยากไปแล้ว
เราก็ไปไปพ
ศวัตโดดทีค่ะไม่วาย